[Música]
la presidenta Dina boluarte rendirá
testimonio el martes ante la fiscalía
peruana por la investigación sobre el
asesinato de más de 60 civiles en las
protestas la mandataria ha sido
criticada por organizaciones defensoras
de Derechos Humanos debido a la
respuesta contra las movilizaciones
las mujeres en México buscan que los
ataques con ácidos se castiguen
penalmente como un intento de
feminicidio solo en 2022 se perpetraron
47 de estas agresiones en France 24
empezamos nuestra serie para conmemorar
el día internacional de los derechos de
la mujer
nuevo golpe a las disidencias en
Nicaragua el gobierno canceló la
personería jurídica del Consejo superior
de la empresa Privada de las 18
asociaciones gremiales que lo conforman
varios ex directivos del cosep se
encuentran entre los más de 200
ciudadanos nicaragüenses que fueron
desterrados hacia Estados Unidos hace un
mes
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda a Andrés Meza Muñoz comenzamos en
Perú en el marco de las manifestaciones
que no cesan desde el pasado 7 de
diciembre la presidenta Dina boluarte
tendrá que comparecer este martes ante
la fiscalía por las acusaciones de
abusos policiales luego de que
organismos como la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
criticaran la dura respuesta oficial
contra los civiles Alba Santana nos
amplía
es uno de los momentos más cruciales
para Dina boluarte desde que asumió como
presidenta de Perú tendrá que comparecer
ante la fiscalía por un tema que la ha
perseguido desde que juramentó el abuso
policial en las manifestaciones
pido perdón por esta situación y por lo
que no se haya dejado de hacer para
evitar esos acontecimientos trágicos
desde ese ocho de diciembre de 2022 Día
de la juramentación la acompañó una
oleada de protestas
como rechazo a la nueva presidenta y
exigiendo elecciones escenas como esta
se han repetido
y muchos han tenido que enterrar a sus
seres queridos tras morir a manos de la
policía durante las manifestaciones
Y es que a pesar de que el gobierno se
ha mantenido firme en negar la
existencia de estos abusos poco a poco
organismos internacionales los han
denunciado desde mediados de diciembre
al inicio de las protestas la cidh
anunció una visita al país debido a
hechos preocupantes en las
manifestaciones el 10 de enero amnistía
internacional pedía el de ese inmediato
de la violencia contra los manifestantes
y solo unos días después la Unión
Europea y la oea manifestaron su
preocupación y tacharon los hechos de
intolerables no se pueden aceptar actos
de vandalismo y mucho menos un uso
desproporcionado de la fuerza por parte
de las autoridades y represión en las
manifestaciones violentando la vida
humana especialmente sobre las
poblaciones que han sufrido desigualdad
y estigmatizaciones el 31 de enero la
cidh condenó oficialmente el uso arbi de
la fuerza por parte del gobierno y a lo
largo de febrero Perú Recibió la condena
de otras organizaciones lo que llevó a
la fiscalía a abrir una investigación en
contra del gobierno en el que boluarte y
su gabinete tendrán que explicar la
muerte de decenas de personas a manos de
la policía el gobierno de Nicaragua
canceló la personería jurídica al
consejo superior de la empresa privada
cosep y a las asociaciones gremiales que
la integran argumentando que no
completaron el proceso de registro
varios ex directivos del concepto se
encuentran entre los más de 200
ciudadanos de nicaragüenses que fueron
desterrados hacia Estados Unidos a
principios de febrero la ampliación de
esta noticia desde antigua con nuestro
corresponsal para Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo
duro golpe para la libre empresa y el
Libre Mercado este lunes en Nicaragua
luego de la decisión del Ministerio de
gobernación de cancelar la personería
jurídica de 18 de los más importantes
gremios empresariales conformados en el
consejo superior de la empresa Privada
de Nicaragua se trata entonces de la
disolución de empresas relacionadas al
sector minero al sector del urbanismo y
de la construcción gremios relacionados
con los textiles con la pesca grandes
industrias que normalmente suelen
exportar sus productos con tasas
preferenciales hacia los Estados Unidos
y que representan un motor económico
para Nicaragua Pero que con la decisión
de hoy del gobierno de Ortega quedan
clausuradas y la razón del orteguismo de
cerrar estas empresas Es que le faltaron
a la transparencia faltaron a la ley por
no entregar los soportes de ventas los
ingresos y egresos de una manera
detallada al gobierno siendo que ellos
Siempre han sido fieles al sandinismo y
en materia de reacciones luz y valentí
empresaria actualmente exiliada y otrora
presidenta de la cámara nacional del
turismo dijo que Nicaragua con esta
decisión Está en camino hacia la
talibanización mientras que Félix
maradiaga férreo opositor de Ortega y
que fue uno de los desterrados
recientemente a Washington el pasado 9
de febrero dijo que esta decisión es la
cubanización del orteguismo
este miércoles 8 de marzo se conmemora
el día internacional de los derechos de
la mujer y por eso durante toda la
semana Franz 24 les Presenta una serie
de reportajes que resaltan los
activismos latinoamericanos contra los
tipos de violencia machista en México la
sobrevivientes de los ataques con ácido
luchan para que este crimen se persiga
como un intento de feminicidio Mario
carbonel nuestro corresponsal en Ciudad
de México nos cuenta la historia
María Elena Ríos sobrevivió a un intento
de feminicidio tras un ataque con ácido
en septiembre de 2019 hoy ya puede
volver a tocar el saxofón pero superar
la agresión ha sido tortuoso te ves muy
grave de salud
te encontrarás inactiva profesionalmente
te vas a deprimir y vas a estar
encerrada en tu cuarto quizá por años
por vergüenza
según datos de la secretaría de salud en
la última década se registraron 797
amenazas o agresiones solo en 2022 hubo
222 amenazas y se perpetraron 47 ataques
con ácido o alguna otra sustancia por
ahora María Elena estudia música en
Ciudad de México pero debe viajar con
frecuencia a Oaxaca donde sufrió el
atentado para asistir a las audiencias
contra el presunto agresor creo que lo
más fácil hubiera sido callarme pero mi
agresor estaba amenazando de muerte
también a mi familia y creo que como
cualquier persona lo que menos deseamos
es vivir con miedo la diputada Marcela
fuente redactó una iniciativa de ley
para castigar con penas de 8 a 12 años
de cárcel y hasta 30 años se haya
agravantes este tipo de agresiones les
deja una serie de consecuencias físicas
psicológicas no solamente a ellas sino a
sus familias Entonces les desgarran la
vida por eso es importante
promoverla como tentativa de feminicidio
las víctimas cuentan con apoyo de la
sociedad civil como la fundación Carmen
Sánchez que trabaja en conseguir ayuda
emocional y física para la
rehabilitación de la sobrevivientes
gestionamos convenios de colaboración
con el sector privado pero también con
público para acompañarlas en el proceso
médico psicológico legal pero también
propiciamos espacios de esparcimiento
social el caso de María Elena y su ardua
búsqueda de Justicia sigue inspirando a
otras víctimas y a la propia legisladora
a visibilizar esta problemática para que
las mujeres en México no sean atacadas
con ácido
en Estados Unidos 23 personas se
enfrentan cargos por terrorismo
doméstico fueron detenidas el domingo en
medio de una manifestación en su mayoría
pacífica contra la construcción de un
centro de entrenamiento policial en
Atlanta Los manifestantes rechazan tanto
la creación de la instalación policial
como que su construcción destroce una
importante zona boscosa más en el
informe de Natalia plazas
en Atlanta las manifestaciones contra la
construcción de un centro de
entrenamiento policial continúan el
domingo 23 personas fueron detenidas
cuando en una protesta mayoritariamente
pacífica un grupo comenzó a lanzar
piedras y bombas incendiarias al lugar
de las obras
como ya he dicho en otras ocasiones el
terrorismo doméstico no será tolerado en
este estado Mientras seguimos respetando
las protestas pacíficas también
continuaremos garantizando la seguridad
en nuestras comunidades la comunidad
rechaza la construcción del centro por
considerar que Atlanta se convertirá en
lo que los manifestantes llaman una City
o ciudad de la policía esto en medio de
pedidos nacionales a reformar Una
institución con constantes denuncias de
violencia entre sus filas también porque
la construcción del centro supone la
destrucción de 34,4 hectáreas de un
importante bosque para la ciudad de 6
millones de habitantes
ignorando los gritos de los residentes
la ciudad de Atlanta se mueve para
destruir del Bosque urbano más grande de
la nación y reemplazarlo con la
instalación de entrenamiento policial
militarizada más grande de América del
Norte
los activistas han acampado durante
semanas cerca a donde se realizan las
obras y han realizado diversas
manifestaciones contra la construcción
con constantes enfrentamientos con la
policía en enero uno de los activistas
Manuel Esteban Páez Terán de 26 años
falleció en un tiroteo de agentes
policiales hasta que este informativo
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]